Welcome back everyone big surprise HBO dropped
the House the Dragon teaser trailer so we'll
break it down there's a whole bunch of game
of thrones Easter eggs.
And references to a song of ice and fire.
So I'll explain what's going on.
Who all the characters are and what it is
that they're referencing of course will be
doing episode videos for this.
Just like I did for the main show so be sure
to subscribe to get everything.
I'll start at the beginning of this and work
our way through shot by shot.
They focus on a couple core characters that
are critical to the dance the dragons the
targaryen civil war that serves as for the
basis for what the stories going to be you
notice that the theme song that they have
playing in the trailer has echoes of the original
game of thrones theme song, but it's a little
more subtle the official theme song for House
the dragons will play over the opening title
scenes will be a little bit different though
range of body is also coming back to do all
the music for House the Dragon he's the person
who did all the music for the original game
of thrones series, so game of thrones probably
has some of the best music of any TV show
ever so I'm expecting House the Dragon to
be the exact same the whole trailer is narrated
by Matt Smith Daemon targaryen talking about
fire and blood.
That's the motto of House targaryen they quoted
that all the time on the main show but Daemon
targaryen is the brother of the current king
of Westeros when the series picks up Viserys
Targaryen the first he's the person the Daenerys
his brother Viserys is named after because
her brother is Viserys the second his brother
the king is being played by Paddy Considine
who some of you probably remember from some
other TV shows and movies that he's done a
fairly prominent actor.
But the trailer starts with Daemon walking
through the halls of Dragonstone obviously
it's very darkly lit most of the scenes are
happening at night so he couldn't tell you
could make at the rockface behind him there
in dragonstone a lot of this is happening
this is him on the beach in present day with
his now wife walking out to meet him the older
version of Rhaenerya Targaryen the leader
of one of the factions in the targaryen civil war
The dance of the dragons.
This is the younger version of Rhaenerya later
in the trailer heavily featured in the footage
to so kind of seems like there either rolling
really hard on flashbacks during House the
Dragon or the present the show with two different
timelines like episodes or large sequences
during episodes will be set in the past intercut
with scene set in present day, but then they
give you a better idea for when the series
actually picks up 200 years before the events
in the main show.
This also covers the period leading up to
the actual dance of dragons.
Like I said the actual war only lasted for
a couple years a lot of the series will be
spent in the time leading up to the actual
war.
Like a full-blown civil war when you see patient
Dragon battles in the sky with the two different
sides going at each other that might not happen
till the later seasons the show.
This is the giant Dragon skull of Balerion
the Black dread.
If you couldn't tell and present day they
showed it underneath the throne room liquid
so she's going to look at it with Tyburn to
talk about weapons that he has these developing
to fight against the nurses dragons in the
past though the big difference is the targaryens
when they still sat on the iron throne the
schools of their dead dragons Balerion the
Black dread included were shown in places
of honor much more prominently around the
red keep because as Matt Smith Daemon targaryen
narrates in the trailer the secret to their power
The targaryen's was there dragons would happen
was though, is that after Robert's rebellion.
When Robert Baratheon took the iron throne.
He took all the schools in the dragons and
put them underneath the red keep in storage
so that he wouldn't have to look at them than
this is a scene of the current hand of the
king when the show picks up.
Notice the pin on his chest their it's Otto
Hightower played by Rhys Ifans who most of
you probably know from something else he's
in a billion big movies and TV shows during
this period in history.
He's head of House Hightower and he's the
father of the present day Queen Alicent Hightower
she's the leader of the other faction in the
targaryen civil war affectionately refer to
as the greens the older version of Alicent
is being played by Olivia Cooke she had she
might be playing the younger and the older
versions in my just wind up being Rhaenerya
that has two different actresses playing the
two different roles but she Rhaenerya are
basically the two people fighting for the
iron throne Rhaenerya is the oldest living
child of King Viserys the first current king
and eventually once he dies that big war for
succession starts the whole idea is that before
he died he named his daughter Rhaenerya the heir apparent
But and after he did die his widow Queen Alicent
said that her oldest son with King Viserys
should be the next king and you get in this
whole conversation about how the line of succession
typically jumps over women.
During this period in history is a very similar
situation to what happened with Jon Snow and
Daenerys and who had the stronger claim for
the iron throne.
The reason why Jon Snow's claim to the iron
throne was stronger than Daenerys was because
the crown passed from the Mad King to his
oldest son Rhaegar targaryen and then to his
only son Jon Snow skipping over Daenerys who
was the Mad King's only living child by the
end of season one of the main show.
As I showed earlier this is King Viserys Targaryen
the first sitting on the iron throne and holding
his valyrian the sword Blackfyre we been waiting
to see a version of Blackfyre somewhere in
live action for so long.
But the cool thing about this period in history
is that the sword had not been lost yet, so
that's why he's holding it year Blackfyre
was the valyrian sword that famously belong
to Aegon the conqueror and what would happen
is the each new king after Aegon would be
given the blade by the previous targaryen
king is a sign of their right to rule that
is until the Blackfyre rebellion, which was
another targaryen civil war.
There were many of them throughout history
that happened about 60 years after the events
of the dance of the dragons that they're doing
on House the Dragon.
So the Blackfyre valyrian sword was still
around for about 60 years after the events
of House of the Dragon knows the ring he's
got his finger wrapped around the hill this
got the sigil of House targaryen on it that
be one of the rings that he just normally
be wearing as the current reigning king what
my early theory is though is that he's going
to wind up being the new Ned Stark of House
the Dragon like them killing them off in a
huge moment at the end of season one.
Maybe because the whole idea is that the actual
dance of the dragons conflict doesn't really
get going until he dies in the war of succession
starts this is the younger version of Rhaenerya
targaryen she was married and had a couple
of children with another person from the Velaryon
Household during this period many years before
the actual war started.
That's why say they might be doing two different
timelines.
Her first husband was Laenor Velaryon of this
character here.
He was the son of the sea snake Corlys Velaryon
who control Driftmark, this island south of Dragonstone here
He was a very powerful person at this point
in history the Velaryon's a vassal House
of House Targaryen and many of them also carry
valyrian blood in their veins just like targaryens.
Thus, that's why they all have the white hair.
What winds up happening though is that he
dies when he's younger, so she gets re-married
to Daemon targaryen that's what you see older
Rhaenerya on the beach of Dragonstone with
Daemon here after they been married this is
just the rest of the valyrian Household here
though knows their sigil is the seahorse usually
sigil's on game of thrones her House the Dragon
now are the easiest ways to identify people
in the show.
If you're not sure who you're looking at you
notice that they're walking into the throne
room at the red keep your king's landing for
a big banquet the scene kind of mirrors the
banquet being held by Ned Stark it winter
fell for Robert Baratheon in the Royal family
during game of thrones episode one on the
main show the be a lot of moments on House
the Dragon that they try to mirror from events
from game of thrones.
This banquet that they're having here in this
scene might be to celebrate King Viserys wedding
to Alicent Hightower or to celebrate one of
their anniversaries or the birth of one of
their children not totally sure in the timeline
here because kind of fuzzy in the background
then they show you bunch of footage from one
of the tournaments there were a couple big
tournaments during this period in history.
So not exactly sure which one.
This is the most significant one was sort
of the beginning of the feud between Rhaenerya
and Alicent like the actual beginning of the
dance of the dragons.
There was a tournament held in 111 AC to mark
the fifth anniversary of Alicent's marriage
to King Viserys Targaryen the first Alicent
came to the tourney wearing a green gown and
Rhaenerya came wearing a black down.
That's why the two different sides in the
targaryen civil war were called the Blacks
and the greens the Blacks were everybody who
supported Rhaenerya's claim to the iron throne
because her father, the King Viserys had named
her his successor, and Queen Alicent leader
of the greens everyone who supported her tried
to say that her son with Viserys should take
the iron throne also funny coincidence like
we talk about a war of succession with a person
named Aegon like you talk about the conflict
between Jon snow and Daenerys that happened
towards the end of the main show Allison's
older son that she was trying to put on the
throne was actually named Aegon he was Aegon
the second as you can tell because Aegon the
conqueror was such a mythical figure within
their family.
There were so many different targaryens all
over their family that were named Aegon he
was their most popular name for the person
actually fighting here in the tournament is
Daemon targaryen Matt Smith character.
You can tell because he's building his valyrian
blade dark sister given to him by his grandfather
King Jaeherys the first when he was knighted
at the age of 16 dark sister had previously
belonged to Daemon's father Baelon targaryen
and before him Aegon sister wife Visneyna
that's why the blade was given the name dark
sister because it was Aegon's dark sister
wife you notice that Daemon's armor is very
similar to the armor worn by Rhaegar targaryen
during Roberts rebellion even though you never
actually see him wearing his armor on the main show
This is what it actually look like during
Robert's rebellion that he couldn't tell who
this is this woman is Mysaria.
She was one of Daemon targaryen's lovers she's
from episodes.
She later winds up becoming mistress of whispers
for Princess Rhaenerya after she marries Daemon
targaryen if you don't remember, that was
basically one of heiresses main jobs he was
master of whispers for the mad King the later
for Robert Baratheon in then briefly for Joffrey
when he was king for just a hot second.
This is Alicent Hightower again after she's
become Queen notice that she's wearing the green gown
Thus the leader of the greens faction in real
big zoom and enhance you probably recognize
that dagger, because that is arias valyrian
dagger.
Like I said the be lots of connections and
Easter eggs for things from the main show
connecting it to the timeline a present day.
I boarded than many videos about the history
of the catspaw's dagger and how little finger
got his hands on it and how he manipulated
events to get into Joffrey's hands in into
the catspaw's hands.
It wasn't clear Joffrey was actually the person
who hire the catspaw not little finger behind
her zoom and enhance you notice is Graham
McTavish she's playing Sir Harold Westerling
on the show.
He's leader of the Kingsguard during this.
Like the Barristan Selmy of this era, you
also notice that the armor is silver very
different from the armor worn by the kingsguard
to present day.
Each time a new king comes to power they're
allowed to alter the kingsguard armor just
a little bit to suit them.
But Robert Baratheon for example, made a huge
change because he put the sigil of House Baratheon
on it replacing the sigil of House targaryen
speaking of sigil's you notice later in this
other footage from a joust during probably
that same tournament that we saw earlier you
see the flag of how stark I don't think that
they confirm who's playing all the Starks
during this era the leader of how stark during
this period was name Cregan Stark he was called
the wolf of the North he had nine children,
so I'm sure we'll see most of them on the
show at some point in probably one of the
other biggest changes on the show is, they
depict their version of the iron throne during
this era much closer to what the actual iron
throne look like in the books with the melted
down swords all over the place all around the throne
This is what it actually looks like in the
books.
Just for comparison, so we're like
half way there.
But during this scene here.
This final scene the trailer.
This is young Rhaenerya walking into look
at the iron throne is Matt Smith Daemon narrates
dreams didn't make us kings dragons did obviously
this scene is meant to mirror the scene of
Daenerys is vision of her walking up to the
iron throne and then later during the game
of thrones finale before she died.
Like her trying to fulfill her dream of the
iron throne.
That's why they film young Rhaenerya here
is meant to make her look kind of like Daenerys,
you also notice in the background to around
these windows they don't have the seven pointed
star the faith in them because that was in
at a till later in history.
The be a lot of other really minor differences
in the set declaration.
But the major buildings were all their like
this is still the red keep they still have
all the major locations in king's landing
in dragonstone all over the different rate
Houses a Westeros so will happen is is the
release more footage before the end of the
year some more teasers of course will do videos
for those when they drop.
If you have any big requests are big questions
about the show.
Just leave them in the comments below will
probably get episodes around April or May
next year the be 10 episodes in season one.
So be a lot more like the scheduling of the
early seasons of the original show.
And speaking of game of thrones.
There's a big game of thrones reunion happening
in the marvel Eternals movie.
I just did a big trailer video for that with
Jon Snow and Robb Stark kit harington Richard
Madden's characters.
You can click here to learn all about that
and click here for all my other House the
Dragon preview videos and more details on
the episodes that you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys in
the next one!